for those of you who don't know me I'm
Sarah soul and I'm the mortgage
professor of organizational behavior
here at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business and my pronouns are she hers
in 2016 my longtime friend and wonderful
collaborator Tom Worster and I launched
the Stanford University lgbtq Executive
leadership program
um at this time there are over 200 lgbtq
plus leaders who have taken the program
and are now proud to be part of our very
active and exciting alumni group who who
gather throughout the world for
continued discussion and to promote and
support one another
this program I was a brainchild of Tom
who was as many of you know the first
openly gay partner at BCG and who was
among the initial Architects and
supporters of that company's employee
Resource Group and other programs that
benefit lgbtq plus people even today at
the firm
Tom was fat was very very passionate
about training lgbtq plus leaders by
building a set of competencies and
skills all seen through the lens of
identity he was also passionate about
building a strong network of LG lgbtq
plus professionals all with the end goal
of ensuring more representation at the
c-suite and on boards so this program
never would have been possible without
Tom's support however as many of you
know he's decided to retire from the
program and while he won't be with us
this year his legacy will live on in the
program that he helped to create and
continues to support
with that I'm very happy to introduce
this year's new co-director this is
somebody who many of you know who've
been part of the program or been around
Stanford University and I'm so happy to
introduce you all to Professor Shelly
Corral who's going to be joining me this
year and for subsequent years as
co-directors Shelley is a co-teacher of
mine she's a collaborator on research
and she's also a co-conspirator on
making Stanford a more welcoming and
inclusive place where we all feel like
we belong and we can contribute to the
mission of the institution
um Shelley's been with the program since
its Inception as one of the faculty
members teaching in the program and
she's also served each year as a
sounding board to me and Tom and Lisa
and others in exec Ed on the content and
possible new sessions and so she's been
a long time advisor of the program
um Shelley brings a whole new energy to
the program because of her long-standing
research both on women's leadership but
also on diversity equity and inclusion
in the workplace and I'll say one more
thing about Shelley before handing this
over to her to say a bit more about
um about what she sees as some of her uh
unique skills which she brings to the
program but one of the things that's so
important about Shelley and her research
program is that she has been one of the
leaders in translational research in
this space and what I mean by that is
that she's been taking what she has
learned in her academic research and
Distilling it into practical guidance
for people running organizations anybody
who desires more Equity inclusion and
belonging and I think this is critical
of course for all leaders but it's of
course an especially great interest to
lgbtq plus people so Shatley let me uh
let me ask you to say a bit more about
yourself and then we will talk more
about the program
thank you Sarah and I want to First just
say I'm delighted to be co-directing the
program with you
um so just a bit more on me and a little
bit about you know kind of what I'm
excited about with the program and kind
of what our hopes are for for the 2023
version of the program my official title
is I'm the Michelle Mercer and Bruce
gold and family professor of women's
leadership here at Stanford I use she
her pronouns in addition to being a
professor um here I'm also the
co-founder and director of a women's
leadership lab here on campus that has
the goal of putting Dei scholarship into
action to drive change and we do this by
partnering with people in organizations
so what excites me about this program
well first as a lesbian scholar when I
was asked to teach in this program back
in 2016 I was just so excited to be
invited and just so proud of Sarah and
Tom for creating this approach this
program it's the first of its kind at a
major business school and I'm just so
deeply honored to be joining Sarah in
co-directing this program we're good
friends that go way back teaching
together and I think we're to have a a
really great time in this program so um
I think the goals for the program from
my view the kind of three things that I
hope that we bring to you first is to
enable you to fully lean into your role
as an lgbtq leader that is to draw on
your identity as a source of strength in
your leadership
the second is to give you the tools to
lead for lgbtq plus inclusion and that
is to create the kind of workplaces
where our where our fellow colleagues
can Thrive and um in advance and then
finally through the activities we have
together to really build a Global
Network of lgbtq leaders um and so we'll
talk about each of these things a little
more as we go forward today but let me
now let's turn it to Sarah who will talk
specifically about the 2023 program
great thank you Shelly and I'm so glad
welcome welcome to the co-directorship
role of the program officially even
though we've been working together as
we've designed this kickoff day today
exactly exactly but let me say a few
things first about what's going to stay
the same this year in terms of what this
program has to offer and then Shelley's
going to talk about some of the new
things that we're bringing in
um first of all as it's been in the past
this will be a week-long Residency
program here at Stanford and it's going
to be filled of course with our highly
motivated well-qualified Global cohort
of leaders we are deep in the admissions
process and uh there are some incredible
participants this year as has been the
case in all of the past years as well
um this means because there's such a
high quality highly motivated
um Global set of leaders that they're
going to going to be rewarding an
intense conversations amongst the
participants but also with the very
talented Stanford faculty members who
will be speaking and teaching in the
program
finally has this been the case in the
other in other years in the previous
years there are several different kinds
of sessions first of all we like to add
a lot of experience experiential
sessions to our programs especially the
lgbtq plus program
um there are going to be sections that
are going to be devoted to leadership
skills and competencies and then of
course we're going to have talented
guest speakers and the the sort of
Stanford faculty members and Shelly will
say a few things about some of the new
faculty that we're bringing in let me
just give you a sense of some of the
topics too which which will stay the
same these are kind of the Bedrock
topics that we've offered since the
Inception of the program albeit in
different ways as um as some of the
thinking on these topics has changed so
some examples of the Bedrock topics
refer to are things around authenticity
as a leader negotiations and also the
Neuroscience of leadership is we think
of as kind of core leadership topics in
terms of some of the experiential
sessions we like to teach a lot of the
group dynamics and group and team
Dynamic sessions using
um experiential uh activities also some
of the activities that will dig into
identity and lgbtq plus and gender
identity will be experiential and then
we also have sessions that are around
collaboration and fostering exchange
with which are Fallen to these
experiential sessions as well now
Shelley's going to talk about something
that we're amping up this year and these
are research-based sessions which are
designed to bring the most cutting-edge
social and Behavioral Science research
on lgbtq plus leadership to you so
Shelly do you want to say a bit about
that yeah and I want to say that this
the the new research sessions that we
are adding really came about from past
participants telling us they wanted to
hear more about the diversity equity and
inclusion type research that
specifically affects lgbtq plus
employees and when the program started
in 2016 there wasn't a whole lot of that
research surprisingly there was lots of
research on gender and race but far less
for members of our community and so
what's happened in the meantime is a lot
of that research has come online so in
the past I taught one session on
creating inclusive workplaces I was
taking all the research there was at the
time I'm now expanding and will be doing
two sessions and plus we have two new
research faculty joining us this year
that are really the kind of I think of
some of the leaders in this area one of
these is sociology Professor from
Stanford named Elia saperstein she's an
expert on how to best measure identities
of all kinds because of her expertise
she was one of the very few people asked
to serve on a panel at the national
academies of science engineering and
medicine that produced a consensus
report titled measuring sex gender and
sexual orientation and this is truly
important because one of the reasons we
haven't had much research in the past on
our community is because our major data
sets in this country while they measure
gender and race did not ask people about
their lesbian gay trans bisexual Etc
identities and therefore we were kind of
silenced from the research that could be
done so as this has started to change we
now have a lot more research in this
area that can allow us to understand the
experiences and the barriers that people
face from our community and so I think
you'll find this to be very interesting
if you're in the program because it will
also kind of inform how you think about
measuring things in your own workplace
when you're doing say engagement surveys
or climate surveys and the like allow us
to better understand the experiences
that people are having in our workplaces
and also to be able to track progress
and then our second new faculty member
is also a sociologist she'll be coming
to us from the University of Michigan
and her name is Aaron SEC and she has
hands down conducted more research on
lgbtq plus people in professional
workplaces than any other scholar and so
she's done work in science organizations
technology organizations the federal
government some really cool work on NASA
and she's going to share this with us
with an eye to thinking about how we can
create more inclusive workplaces for
lgbtq plus employees so really excited
for these new developments in the 2023
program and now Sarah I'll kick it back
to you to give folks a sense of how how
the week will be going great and
incidentally as I start this I know that
you may have some questions on the
program and because we're tight on time
today because we want to be sure to get
to a wonderful part of the program where
we get to interview some past
participants in the program we want to
encourage you to um send any questions
you may have by email to Lisa Blair
there will be a slide with an email
stress and all kinds of other
information toward the end of the
webinar so I just wanted to sort of flag
that because I know Shelly and I both of
us are so excited that we're speaking
really quickly and you probably have
lots and lots of questions and we'll be
happy to answer those by email
afterwards so let me say a little bit
about how the week is going to unfold
and we're really excited about what
we've designed here in terms of an
experience for participants
now as we said and we've said it and
this was something I said when I talked
about Tom who was one of the co-founders
of this program and the goals are to of
course enhance participants leadership
competencies and skills of course as
Shelley just said we want to expose
everybody to the most the latest in
research and and and to think about ways
in which we can take that research as
leaders and bring it to our
organizations in meaningful ways but we
also want to make sure that we continue
to build the network within cohorts but
then also across cohorts so let me say a
little bit about how we're thinking
about some of these goals during the Arc
of of each day
so um as some past participants that
I've seen uh attending the webinar know
we begin
um each day with an optional Fitness and
very healthy breakfast and one of the
things that we believe is that if we can
get people together in informal ways
particularly at the beginning of the day
with optional Fitness we can build
strong connections and bonding uh some
of us have wonderful pictures of our
fitness mornings uh together out on the
Stanford track and it's also a great way
to experience Stanford University but
also to build those kinds of connections
and so on and of course the fitness is
designed for people at every single
level and with every single ability so
it's very inclusive important something
new this year that we're doing is Shelly
and I are curating
um uh what we're calling uh micro
learnings and what we're going to do
with these is we'll begin after
breakfast each day with a curated set of
topics for people to engage in a small
group discussions we're going to be
rotating these groups every single day
to maximize
um uh connections across and within this
cohort and each of these micro learnings
is going to be something topical and
important to lgbtq plus leaders
um we of course will suggest folks to
take these sitting outside in the
wonderful California Sunshine if
possible and we hope that this will be
ways to engage in some smaller group
discussions throughout the week of
course we will have daily programming by
the top faculty that we've talked about
and these will mirror the types of
sessions that we outlined above these
experiential sessions the research-based
sessions and sessions on leadership
competencies and skills each day we
share meals together and we have
relaxing dinners and drinks outside
um there's plenty of time built into the
program for personal reflection for
discussion with peers and additional
discussion with faculty and um and folks
that are supporting the program as well
and then as we've done in the past we
will have an alumni reception ideally
with uh some sort of programming
beforehand that's open to everybody I
say ideally because last year we wanted
that to be open to everybody but coveted
protocols made it such that we couldn't
but hopefully this year that will change
and what we want and we hope and what
our goal is of the alumni reception is
to really begin the cross cohort
networking of of our leaders and so we
hope that that will continue
so we're really excited about what we've
put together in terms of content but
also the structure of the program again
all designed to build this network but
also to build leadership skills and
competencies all with the goal of
increasing representation
um in the c-suite and and on boards
so with that it's time now for kind of
our main event uh and and this is where
we get the wonderful opportunity to have
a conversation with two of our alums
from the program and so I'm very happy
to introduce these two folks um to you
Shelly and I are going to interview them
going back and forth but we really hope
that this will give you a sense of the
program and how it has influenced two
leaders so let me Begin by just quickly
telling you who we have with us here
today we're so happy to have Tom Simons
who who took the lgbtq program last
summer and Tom is the talent acquisition
director at Google deepmind and is
joining us today from New York
the second person that we have with us
is deepti Rao who was in the program in
2019 and is currently a product leader
at meta deeply is joining us today from
Nepal thank you for for coming deep
today thank you for coming Tom we're so
delighted to have you with us and so
delighted to have you sharing with our
participants today some of your
experiences with the program
so I'm going to kick I'm going to kick
off the discussion today first
um by by asking Tom a few questions and
at Tom in some of the discussions that
we've had and that the folks here at
Stanford have had with you
you've mentioned that something special
clicked I think I'm paraphrasing what
you've said something special clicked
for you after you attended last year's
program
could you describe for us what this
change was in your leadership style and
also in your career and what this
special clicking was yeah sure
um and just a quick hello to everyone
it's great to uh it's great to be here
um so Sarah said I'm Tom
um I use the pronounce he him
um and um I was
kind of reflecting on the program
um before before this call and walking
into the program I had I guess like
three overarching development buckets
and that was to to learn unlock and
improve
um and it's fair to say there was a ton
of learning moments um throughout the
program but a real standout for me was
um really connecting with my authentic
leadership style and also learning that
I'm enough
um and that was a really powerful moment
which spoke to years of imposter
syndrome and masking and various other
kind of manifested in in in various
other ways and what I found super cool
about the program is that once once I
had these like aha moments um you would
then you then had the opportunity to to
really think about adding some practical
tools to your toolkit so for example
around communication and how to create
effective strategy Maps uh design
thinking and harnessing humor like
there's loads of stuff which I walked
away with
um that actually really helped
um bring that feeling to life so I think
for me like like all of it combines
um meant that I
went back and I was refreshed and
um just like a more authentic and more
comfortable and self-compassionate with
with myself
um which actually I think has
revolutionized how I've how I've been um
seen as a leader over the last year
um that's so well said and we hear from
so many of our participants
um something very similar about what you
said about imposter uh syndrome or
masking or covering and so on and so I'm
really glad that you called that out for
folks because
um it's it's an important theme
throughout the program as you know to to
how do you you know lean in
authentically to your own um own self
and and harness that as you said so
thank you for
um thank you for so
um eloquently articulating that
so you know each year we refresh the
program in various ways and we try a lot
of different things and each year we
always are trying to surpass the
expectations of our participants
um so your role today of course is in
Global Talent acquisition in the field
of AI for Google so how do you think
Stanford can help expand the pool of top
lgbtq plus talent for leading Brands
like Google
yeah it's a great it's a great question
I guess firstly I do want to acknowledge
and say thanks to to you both Sarah and
Shelley and the whole Stanford crew for
for running this program and also for
running events like this to help raise
awareness and also uh just to stay
relevant um like it was super cool to
hear how you were evolving the program
and and the new content and that sounds
great
um so I for me that that shows real
allyship so I wanted to say thanks and
and and and and acknowledge about
um and Stanford does have it has an
incredible reputation right it has an
incredible Global reputation
um so I think it's just about ensuring
how you are to your earlier Point like
like connecting with the right networks
on on the right platforms but also I
like I don't think it just sits with you
at Stanford
um I think it sits with with past
participants like myself on how we can
help raise awareness and and attract the
talent pool
um so I've been thinking about for
example like how I can help spread
um spread the word of the program across
across Google and where I work and
across my networks and Sarah also also
kind of made made me reflect on a really
great exercise that you ran during the
program on the strength of weak ties and
this idea that that that weak ties allow
clusters of people to access information
which can then lead to New Opportunities
um and and I think there's something in
that so I've been really giving thought
to to actually like how
how I can feed into that uh to kind of
bring more
um
uh Talent into the program
thanks thanks and thanks for calling out
that session uh we are going to play
with that very session again uh this
year because we think it's so important
to thinking about networks in in
different ways as opposed to how we
often think about networks as leaders
and so on so thanks for calling that
outcome and and thank you by the way for
um for your appreciation of the Stanford
team and and what we're doing it means
it means a lot to us to hear that thanks
so one more quick question before I hand
it over to Shelley to do some do some
questioning of you folks
um so when you first when you when you
first showed up here at Stanford what
about the program sort of surprised you
the most and what specifically did you
wish to take back with you to your own
career and and for others in the network
as we've been talking about
yeah I think I think what what surprised
me the most is how immersive the
experience is
um I um I I think there was a really
good balance of classroom learning but
but and you've mentioned this already
and actually like there was a really
good balance of the classroom learnings
but also time to connect with the cohort
in large forums in small breakouts in
lunches breakfast like whatever the
forums was and and that was particularly
powerful I think when considering the
lgbtq plus space and just having time
and space to hear about each other's
lived experiences
um that was pretty special
um like I know for me like I I felt I
genuinely feel like I met a really
amazingly supportive group of leaders
um we showed vulnerability we shared our
experiences
um and I think that's that's really
helped me open my eyes to my journey as
a leader
um and in terms of what I wanted to take
back I think I mentioned this before but
for me it was a like a practical toolkit
I'm quite practical and tangible so I
like to have like like tools that I can
I can use to help me develop but also to
have that academic grounding and and
that was that was really great
um and that kind of combined with an
awareness of my journey and how my
journey as like through an lgbtq lens
like how that's influenced my
um my role as a leader
excellent well said well said Tom thank
you thank you so much I really
appreciate hearing directly um from you
again because I I've I've missed you
since you were in the program and I've
also missed deep fee from a few years
ago and so Shelly I'm gonna hand it over
to you uh to to ask a few questions I'm
glad to and Tom thank you so much and
deep the youth I can't believe you're
here from Nepal that's really just
really touched by both of your
dedication to the program and your
willingness to be here um today and so
um neither you were in the program back
in 2018 if I if I have this correctly
and um and you know two years after that
of course covet hit and um and and
shelter in place was in progress and
Sarah and Tom made the decision there
which I really understand to pause the
program at that time thinking that we
didn't want to host the program again
until we could have people back in
person and so I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about kind of the
impersoneness of this program and the
kind of the need for human connection
and the kind of networks that Tom
alluded to as well and kind of what
value that gave you
sure uh first of all thank you so much
for having me it's uh I'm I I was super
excited about joining this all day even
though I was traveling to Nepal uh like
I was really looking forward to this so
uh really happy to be here
um yeah and Shelly like you mentioned uh
one of the the highlights of the program
is the the whole uh in person uh
interactions that it facilitates so uh I
met people from all over the world uh of
course Tom from the UK but I also met
people from Australia and other parts of
the US and uh we probably wouldn't have
connected so well if it weren't for all
of us being together uh on campus for
over a week I actually lived very close
I live very close to the Stanford campus
in Redwood City but I made it a point to
actually live on campus to have the full
experience uh and then we uh had our
lunches and breakfasts and dinners
together the food was awesome that's
another class
and uh and yeah so and all the breakout
sessions and all the sessions were
really more impactful because there was
that sharing of ideas the very organic
sharing of ideas and stories and uh
lived experiences uh so I think that
really really made it special
the food is good and I live in Menlo
Park so we're practically neighbors so
um so the other thing that I heard about
your experience is that you really had
kind of an Innovative breakthrough
moment during one of the design sessions
and that you took what you learned from
that session back to your team and then
ultimately to what was called Facebook
at the time
um and so I wonder if you could say a
little bit more about that and how that
unfolded for you
yeah so one of the highlights of the the
course was the design thinking session
so we had like a whole day of workshops
uh Sarah's I see you smiling so uh it
was awesome we really loved it and at
the end of the the session there was
like a small project where we could
apply uh the whatever we learned in the
session uh and then uh kind of come up
with a project
um so me and a couple other folks uh so
we were like a team that uh was putting
design thinking in action and that's
when we came up with this idea of you
know uh uh lgbtq business Maps uh so
there was no real good way of finding uh
businesses that were owned by you know
people from the lgbtq community uh so it
was great and uh it really helped us
kind of think through what the features
would be how this would be beneficial
um and uh then I went back and uh took
this to Facebook and uh we actually
hacked it out in a hackathon uh because
it made sense for Facebook to be the
place where you would look for
businesses at that point it was called
Facebook pages of course now it's
evolved a little bit uh so the hackathon
idea was a great success we built it out
uh we even like demoed it to our CTO uh
and uh we won the audience Choice Award
for the hackathon uh so it was all
thanks to uh the design thinking session
uh and actually now there is a way where
you can find diver's own businesses not
just lgbtq but black owned women-owned
any diver Zone business on Facebook you
can actually look for them through the
app so this was actually incorporated
into the uh into the actual Global
Facebook version as well
I love that story and I just I I I I
know that Sarah you probably feel this
his way as well but just love knowing
that the experience produced something
so concrete and so valuable to so many
people so that's just a it's just it's a
touching for us to hear I think it's
instructors so thank you very much for
for sharing that I just one more
question for you and you know when the
when our LGBT leaders gather I mean one
of the things that I've really loved
about this program is kind of the
passion for storytelling and in
particular the way over time in the
program
um we all start to share kind of our
various coming out stories and the
coming out chapters of Our Lives as
employees and to me this has just been
really super special and I I wonder if
you could reflect for yourself on how
this part of the program affected you
yeah it was uh it was truly uh you know
very touching to learn about how coming
out is such an important experience in
everyone's lives
um I thought you know coming from India
where it's not so
um the society is a little bit more
conservative than say the US I thought
maybe I had it rough but then when I
heard some of the stories from some of
the other folks uh that actually lived
and that grew up in the U.S as well but
it was still so much harder for them uh
so I realized that coming out is a big
deal in everybody's lives uh so and this
was again facilitated through or we
actually had a a session on storytelling
and uh how important it is how you can
actually have a deep impact uh through
the power of Storytelling uh so that
session also helped this kind of frame
our coming out stories in that context
uh uh and uh actually I took this back
again uh to Facebook Facebook then meta
now uh so we actually celebrated coming
out day in October uh that year uh so I
did a full feature on I know getting
people to come out and share their
stories so every day of October we share
coming out stories from various
employees from around the globe so
people reached out to me uh at work like
after that saying that this really kind
of helped them reflect and also it it
made a lot of difference a lot of their
co-workers also reached out to them
afterwards uh to you know kind of uh
Express their support uh so that was
also really really uh
heartwarming
thank you thank you
um Sarah so I think you have a question
now that you want to ask to both of you
yeah no I will but first of all deeply I
wanted to thank you again for um you
know I heard the story about the design
thinking and the application and I I
just want to hear it I'm going to replay
this webinar all of the time because I
love it when we teach something you know
sort of as Tom said about the the um the
session on strong and weak ties and so
on I love it when it has that kind of an
impact on people but also on
organizations and the world that is the
motto of the GSB to change lives
organizations in the world I always add
the bigger better
good but so thank you thank you for that
too so I one question and this is for
both of you and maybe we'll ask Tom to
speak first and then we'll ask ask DP to
comment on this too so you know we think
of ourselves at Stanford as um a global
resource and a gathering place with an
ex extremely powerful convening power if
you will
um and and many of our participants in
the program as you've alluded to have
come here from over two different
countries to date so I mean two dozen uh
Nations to date which is a lot and so we
are creating this wonderful Global
Network of lgbtq plus leaders
um and as we think about this and I'm
I'm wondering how we at Stanford can do
our most to meet the needs of different
culture and Regional differences for
lgbtq plus leaders and Executives from
from every continent including including
of course South Asia and Europe so given
your backgrounds I'm wondering if you
could speak to this question and maybe
we'll ask Tom to speak first and then
we'll hand it over to deepti yeah I
think um from a
um like like putting conversations
together that we've had on this on this
thread so it's it's like around how do
we expand
um like in the networks in the right
place but also I think like you're doing
a great job and uh and and to kind of
keep doing but to let us know how we can
sponsor and help to attract people to
this program because it is a genuinely
a great program that we should be
pulling people in and I also think
um
you do a good job of listening like to
like to your teacher to your first point
around actually we've redesigned some of
the program based off the back of
feedback that we've heard from past
participants I mean that that that's
that's really great and I think that's
also the same when you think about
um like cultural and Regional
differences of the cohort and how
attendees uh learn how they um like like
what they're used to from kind of a
clustering perspective a classroom
learning perspective I think as much as
you can be open and and to kind of
listen and and to hear from them and I
think that will that will kind of
continue to stand you in really good
Stead
thank you yeah thanks Tom very design
thinking
approach I think right leave me
yeah I think uh the one of the best
parts is being able to meet people from
all over the globe I didn't know it was
uh two dozens that's awesome uh and uh
and yeah I think uh it definitely gives
you a lot of perspective about how lives
are different or same uh even though we
have so many cultural differences uh I
think at the at the end of the day like
we do have this common shared journey of
you know uh having to you know come out
having to kind of face a little bit of
uh non-acceptance and all of that so
there's that shared Journey but there's
also in context of each person's uh
cultural uh experiences so that's
amazing
um so yeah thank you thank you for uh
enabling this uh Meetup to happen as
well uh from across the world
um uh especially uh I think it's also
super relevant in India because right
now they're debating uh same marriage in
the Supreme Court so it's all the more
relevant for uh you know uh for India to
have to have people attend the course
like this so that uh everyone from the
community is uh aware that there's uh
there's hope uh as well outside so uh
and being able to connect with all these
uh awesome people from across the globe
uh really inspires you to bring your
true self to whatever you do
well said as we get towards the end here
I'm just wondering Tom or deeply is
there anything else you might share or
want to share with the folks who have um
who have taken time to to call in today
any other anecdotes or special moments
or something you might want to share
with folks
uh Tom I'll start with you again since
we're going back and forth a bit yeah I
think I I guess
um
if I rewind back to when I was
submitting my application
um and when I when I found out I was I
was on the program like that like that
there was a moment of intimidation with
that I was I based in London
um I didn't I hadn't been to Stanford
before
um I've been educated in in the UK I
wasn't quite sure what to expect like
the prospect of staying on campus like
what like like who were the cohort so
there were loads of questions swirling
around my head
um so anyone who's feeling that right
now
um like I would say I I hear you I feel
you
um but I would strongly like encourage
you to hit the apply button and and and
and to give it a go from the minute that
I stepped foot onto the campus to the
minute that I left it was incredibly
welcoming really supportive and I'm not
someone who is
um hugely extrovert and I was also
worried about having to spend like the
whole amount of time with people but
actually
it it it it went so quickly like it was
amazing like you genuinely build the
most like like the strongest connection
so anyone who was feeling apprehensive I
would say
um I hear you but I would encourage you
to um to push through and you won't
regret it
thanks Tom yeah I would last one on that
and uh it's definitely an opportunity of
a lifetime uh you will leave the program
having made lifelong friends and of
course gaining so much knowledge
learning from awesome uh instructors
like Sarah and all the Stanford
professors so I would definitely
definitely encourage uh taking the time
to do this program
thank you so much both and I'll say from
The Faculty perspective we hear year and
year
um that faculty who are invited to teach
in the program feel like they have
become better instructors because
they've um they have taken their
material and tried to see it through the
lens of identity and some have done a
better job than others well you know
that's always going to be the case but
but everyone says that they have
improved as instructors improved as
people as a result of being part of this
program and so I think that there's an
impact there that is important to call
out as well
so yeah so with that we are at the end
of our time I want to thank
um Tom and Dixie for for taking the time
for uh coming here with us to share
their
um their their feedback about the
program their ideas and their thoughts
as we go forward I also want to thank of
course
um the Stanford team uh who has put
together the logistics of the the
webinar our dear friend Bob whittick
who's been with us also since the start
of the program uh as well and Lisa Blair
who has been with us since the start of
the program too we we would not be able
to run this program without you all and
uh with that we just want to remind
everybody that the application is online
easily completed uh the deadline of is
June 16th and at the end of this webinar
there's going to be
um a slide with a web address and ways
to connect with questions I know that we
didn't make this open for question from
participants but we hope that you will
send any questions you have to the
contact information that you see up on
the screen now and we really hope to see
your applications and to welcome you
here at Stanford University to the
California Sunshine uh at the end of
July
and thank you everyone I want to just
Sarah I want to just take the
opportunity to thank you and uh for for
all the work you've done putting this
program together The Bravery of that
your commitment to the program and um
you're just like the best ally a person
could have and I I so I just want to
thank you from the bottom of my heart
and just to let folks know if you should
show up you're going to be walking into
a program that's been very well curated
by uh by Sarah and the former co-leader
Tom so thank you and Shelly's editions
thank you Shelly stay well everybody we
hope to see you soon